bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de parlement hebdo en copa et mickaël
szames us bonjour michael sens pour 45
minutes d'actualité politique et
parlementaire toujours dominé évidemment
par les répliques de l'ombre de choc
cahuzac nous reviendrons sur le shaq de
moralisation annoncée par françois
hollande
le programme pour les parlementaires non
cumul avec certaines activités et
surtout publication du patrimoine une
future obligation qui ne passe pas bien
notamment auprès du président de
l'assemblée pierre moscovici toujours
dans le collimateur de l'opposition qui
l'accuse d'avoir voulu couvrir jérôme
cahuzac après les révélations de
médiapart les présidents des commissions
des finances et de l'assemblée du sénat
sont allés là à bercy ils se sont dits
peu convaincus par les arguments de
l'administration fiscale
enfin nous irons au sénat la haute
assemblée a fini l'examen du projet de
loi sur le mariage pour tous
ambiance un peu tendue dans la dernière
ligne droite l'étape suivante c'est le
retour à l'assemblée pour une deuxième
lecture est avec nous pour commenter
toute cette actualité laurence rossignol
bonjour bonjour sénatrice de l'oise vous
êtes la nouvelle porte parole du parti
socialiste
vous êtes vice présidente de la
commission du développement durable
c'est au sénat et vous êtes l'une des
fondatrices de la gauche durable c'est
un club du auprès du parti socialiste a
expliqué c'est un petit peu comme cela
et vous prenez un nouveau modèle de
développement fondé sur la transition
écologique mais aussi la révolution
numérique et vous on va lancer un appel
pour tous ceux qui veulent vous suivre
mais vous twittez énormément de l'une
des femmes politiques en france qui
twittait le plus en a cherché et c'est
vrai alors c'est une tradition dans
cette émission les parlementaires dresse
votre portrait vous propose de les
écouter c'est quelqu'un qui gagne à être
connu moi j'apprécie beaucoup cette
personne qui est d'ailleurs
très solidaires au moins il faut se
pouvait compter sur elle pour l'avoir à
vos côtés puis c'est quelqu'un qui est
déterminé dynamique qui est qui va au
fond des choses et femmes est très
intelligente travailleuses politique
c'est quelqu'un qui connaît très bien
les grands problèmes de la planète les
problèmes la biodiversité de la pénurie
des ressources naturelles et les
questions liées à la transition
énergétique donc pour nous c'est
évidemment une interlocutrice de grande
qualité elle est présente en commission
présente en séance et on sent que c'est
une femme vraiment de conviction qui
défend les sujets sur lesquels elle
travaille elle a un côté carey quoi
voilà
bon maintenant il faut parfois un peu
sortir du cadre militant si on veut
avancer mais je sais pas un proche peut
parfaitement défendre ses convictions
les temps militant n'était pas le sujet
un peu trop militant dit roger karoutchi
est ce que c'est un tort est ce que
c'est une faute
écoutez on a été lu et on s'est engagé
en politique pour transformer la société
et pour essayer de convaincre qui on
peut faire des choses et je suis assez
fière d'être une militante
parce qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut avant
tout considérer avec les français c'est
la possibilité de changer les choses là
lutter contre l'impuissance du politique
négatif à tous car il a du mal à
discuter avec vous dao dire un peu les
ans on sait qu'au sénat il faut souvent
on dit raison à ben disons que j'y
passais pas une vie sénatrice quoi donc
je me suis adapté et j'ai arrondi un peu
mes angles c'est vrai mais j'ai des
convictions et je les défends mais je
respecte celle des autres quand elles
sont pas les miennes féministe
convaincue c'est vrai aussi
je vous rappelle peut-être c'était le 18
janvier dernier il ya un sénateur en
tout cas qui s'en rappellent écouter
regarder
et puis on commence juste après pardon
vous pouvez répéter un petit le plus
fort ce que vous venez de dire monsieur
le sénateur vous venez de dire parce que
des fois que ce serait pas où j'ai eu
dix ans vous venez de dire à mon propos
pendant que je parlais de la parité
c'est qui cette nana je souhaite que
soient bien inscrire votre nom s'il vous
plaît
monsieur sido je le crois que vous avez
gagné peut-être ce matin la palme du
misogyne
bof de cette assemblée alors c'était
lors d'une discussion sur les binômes
dans les collectivités territoriales
j'ai dû recevoir beaucoup de textos de
tweets de derrière
j'ai reçu un très joli message d'une
fille qui fait un blog etc a écrit
depuis que j'ai vu ce petit cette petite
vidéo
je me suis demandé combien de fois dans
la journée je me laisser marcher sur les
pieds sans robbie fait elle dit
maintenant après avoir vu lens rossignol
s'exprime au sénat j'ai décidé que je
serais plus rien passer et c'est ce à
quoi le croire c'est ce qui m'a fait le
plus plaisir de tout ce que j'ai lu il
va y avoir de la révolution dans l'est
de la rébellion dans les bureaux et ce
sera pas forcément une mauvaise chose
allez on va commencer avec l'actualité
de la semaine le grand chantier de la
semaine donc moralisation transparence
il y avait le choc de compétitivité le
choc de simplification voici le choc de
moralisation cette semaine dans la
droite ligne de la sphère cahuzac
françois hollande présente les deux
grands axes de son plan transparence
pour la vie politique et lutte contre la
fraude fiscale et les paradis fiscaux
le résumé est signée jean baptiste à
aulas les annonces de la semaine
dernière était tombée à plat aujourd'hui
françois hollande détaille un projet de
moralisation de la classe politique
une haute autorité sera créé totalement
indépendante elle contrôlera les
déclarations de patrimoine mais aussi
les déclarations d'intérêts des membres
du gouvernement des parlementaires des
responsables des grands exécutifs locaux
et des dirigeants des grandes
administrations
les ministres devront publier leur
patrimoine dès lundi
les parlementaires ils seront obligés
après le vote de la loi des
parlementaires qui ne pourront plus
cumuler leur mandat avec certaines
activités professionnelles la loi
dressera la liste des métiers à risques
les avocats d'affaires pourrait en faire
partie
françois hollande averti les
parlementaires condamné pour fraude
fiscale
ils seront inéligibles temporairement ou
définitivement la fraude fiscale et
financière est le deuxième grand
objectif de françois hollande
j'ai donc décidé le premier ministre l'a
présenté ce matin la création d'un
parquet financier c'est-à-dire un
procureur spécialisé avec une compétence
nationale qui pourra agir sur les
affaires de corruption et de grande
fraude fiscale un office central de
lutte contre la corruption et la fraude
fiscale sera créé
il s'agit de coordonner l'action du fisc
de la justice et de la police
enfin la france déclare la guerre aux
paradis fiscaux
tout pays qui ne coopèrent pas sera
considérée comme un paradis fiscal
une liste sera actualisée chaque année
le gouvernement meute elles évitent le
texte sera présenté en conseil des
ministres le 24 avril alors leurs autres
signalerait s'intéresse à ce qui
concerne tout particulièrement les élus
les parlementaires dont fait partie le
volet transparence contrôle des
patrimoines
il existait déjà une commission qui
s'appelait commission pour la
transparence financière de la vie
politique avec rien moins que didier
migaud où le vice-président du conseil
d'état
pourquoi une nouvelle commission elle ne
va pas avoir tellement de moyens
supplémentaires à ce qu'on remplace pas
simplement une commission par une autre
non je crois pas je crois que si on doit
comparer avec une autre commission et la
manière dont on peut travailler ce type
de commission et contrôler il faut plus
tôt pour comparer avec la commission qui
examine nos comptes de campagne et qui
est capable en quelques mois d'examiner
les comptes de campagne de plusieurs
milliers de candidats est très
sérieusement pour les valider ou les
invalides et là on va avoir une haute
autorité qui aura la charge de contrôler
les patrimoines des élus puis ensuite de
les publier
j'aurais peut-être une petite précision
ce qui va être contrôlé c'est pas le
patrimoine de l'élu va pas dire à
monsieur ou madame untel il a trop de
patrimoine un joli patrimoine - pas joli
patrimoine ce qu'on va contrôler c'est
comment entre le début du mandat et la
fin du mandat
ce patrimoine a évolué et est ce qu'il
s'il a augmenté est-ce qu'il a augmenté
dans une limite normale est
proportionnel au revenu
vous allez quand même devoir déclarer
votre patrimoine quoi qu'il arrive ils
déclarent déjà on le déclare déjà mais
sauf qu'elles veulent trop de public qui
va être rendu public le patrimoine des
ministres va être rendu public lundi est
celui des parlementaires
à l'issue de la louisiane voilà message
bien sûr non seulement je voudrais moi
je n'ai pas de problème avec cette
publication du patrimoine de la question
comme tout le monde votre patrimoine se
montait à quoi je vous ai déjà répondu à
cette question je crois un 'très locale
oui voit ses passants allant orient
c'est ma sortie barry bannan bon
d'accord est ce que la pression quand
même leur offre signol hockey
transparence
en tout cas ça on l'a compris de la part
de françois hollande est ce que vous
n'avez pas l'impression que c'est un
contre-feu une opération de com pour
enrayer l' affaire qui a eu jacques non
ça fait longtemps que on a besoin en
france d'avancer à dessus et que l'art
est la résistance vers les résistances
les réticences sont importantes et je
crois que la sphère cahuzac est plutôt
la sphère qui met tout le monde au pied
du mur l'autorégulation n'a pas bien
fonctionné donc maintenant il faut un
cadre de régulation plus ferme et c'est
une bonne occasion d'avancer parce que
on l'a pas suffisamment fait par
ailleurs moi je me sens pas
personnellement en tant que
parlementaires concernés par les
turpitudes de monsieur cahuzac ce qu'il
a fait est un acte individuel mais je me
sens concerné
collectivement parce que on est tous nos
propres mais vous savez sur les
parlementaires sur les églises sur les
ministres tout le monde bien sûr mais je
connais peu de groupes qui n'est pas
brebis galeuses jour penser à une
anecdote que j'avais vu dans les faits
divers avaient une préfète qui avait
vendu le mobilier de la préfecture à des
antiquaires
je crois pas que ça jette un doute sur
la probité de l'ensemble des prêts tél
mais après je suis sûr qu'on a contrôlé
un peu plus dans les préfectures
commencent à se passer de démentir cette
web empêchera pas quelqu'un de mentir de
chinois ne peut empêcher qui que ce soit
de mentir
mais cette fois là va nous faire
progresser dans un domaine où la france
était pas franchement exemplaire dans sa
capacité à mettre en place des
procédures de transparence et de
contrôle
je comprends que des collègues et on
s'est un peu déplaisant bon voilà il ya
un petit côté fracture de l'ain team
mais en même temps c'est pas un drame si
les patrimoines évolue normalement alors
avec les collègues justement et non des
moindres un claude bartolone président
de l'assemblée nationale était reçue à
matignon jeudi sur la question il n'est
pas du tout de votre avis lui il est
contre cette publication des patrimoines
et il va nous dire pourquoi
sur cette question aussi du patrimoine
des élus nous serons en mesure de faire
des propositions qui permettent de faire
concilier à la fois la transparence sans
pour autant tomber dans le voyeurisme
parce que vous croyez réellement pour
prendre un exemple d'actualité que en
améliorant la transparence du patrimoine
ça permet à monsieur cahuzac de déclarer
son compte à st à singapour
voyeurisme inefficacité n'y va pas de
main morte un président de l'assemblée
sur sa dernière question là ça n'aurait
pas empêché la sphère cahuzac
non ce n'aurait pas plus cher qu'une zac
mais il ya des types de mensonges et de
délinquance qu'on peut pas empêcher une
société ad d'evian et ne peut pas
totalement les contrôler ce ne sera pas
une loin c'est le je crois que c'est
l'opportunité pour faire avancer un
sujet sur lequel ça coinçait jusqu'à
présent et on a besoin de recréer la
confiance avec les français et les
parlementaires ont besoin de dire aux
français nous n'avons rien à cacher par
ailleurs juste pour par pense que des
coups de marteau l'homme je pense qu'il
va falloir que l'on trouve le moyen que
le contrôle sur les patrimoines soit
bien fait par la haute autorité et qu'on
fasse pas l'espèce de contrôle en ligne
participatif avec les gens qui épluche
les patrimoines et qu'ils disent à
mézidon la maison de monsieur à elle
elle vaut temps c'est incroyable ma
belle soeur elle a acheté la même dans
la rue d'en face et de la paie 50 mille
de plus haut risque ce n'est pas pareil
très justement il ya des propositions
qui ont été faites hier par les deux
présidents de groupes parlementaires par
bruno le roux et françois rebsamen qui
vise à garantir à la fois que le
patrimoine là le volume du patrimoine
soit clairement public et qu'en même
temps on s'épargne cette espèce de
curiosité et en plus sur des éléments
qui peuvent varier ce qu'il faut mais
surtout sur le patrimoine je le redis ce
qu'il faut c'est contrôlé patrimoine en
début de mandat patrimoine enfin le
patrimoine des élus n'est pas en soi un
sujet de suspicion ce qui est la
suspicion c'est comment ce patrimoine
augmentent pendant la période où ils
sont élus il doit augmenter
normalement et pas de manière
spectaculaire et vous entendez aussi les
personnes qui disaient pourquoi pas le
conjoint ou la conjointe est ce qu'il
faut déclarer pour tout le monde mais
écouter les gens qui sont mariés sous le
régime de la communauté des biens vont
devoir déclarer leur patrimoine avec
celui de leurs conjoints fallait la
moitié voler jusqu'ici
bah non parce que les enfants si l'on
soit ils ont soit si long ils sont
adultes ils sont civilement majeur et
ils ont un patrimoine propre et on peut
pas leur demander de le relier à sud est
par les enfants déjà il faut que les
parents soient potion quand il loue un
appartement alors demandé en plus de
traîner le patrimoine de leurs les
français leur colère d'accord avec cette
opération transparence pas de 77% selon
selon un sondage
est ce que vous pensez tout de même que
nous sommes préparés dans nos esprits
allez dans cette transparence un peu
comme les pays nordiques le faut est ce
que les français sont préparés à cela
les français sont demandeurs aujourd'hui
de signe fort de restauration de la
confiance
ce ne sera pas ça ne se résoudra pas
uniquement comme ça il ya le fait que
l'on ne traîne pas des pieds on ne donne
pas du tout l'impression que ça nous
pose problème ça ne me pose pas problème
enfin de pose pas problème à l'immense
majorité de mes collègues mais il faudra
aussi donné des signes importants et des
résultats sur ce qui les intéresse quand
même aussi grandement qu'est la
politique économique et sociale
voilà mais on va devenir comme les
nordiques alors c'est pas les pays me
donne pas le même rapport à l'argent que
nous on a un rapport un petit peu
fascination détestation qui finalement
créé un climat
quand une ministre dit que l aps l isf
bon ça sur sûr
twitter ça fait des vagues ça fait du
bruit on en parle c'est la santé des
gens oui mais ça c'est l'inconvénient
des publications isolé je suggère à tout
le monde de publier en groupe comme ça
c'est une démarche collective et lundi
pour les mamies le but ce n'est pas
d'exhiber nos patrimoines le but est
d'avoir une démarche démocratique
nouvelle
donc c'est une démarche collective c'est
pas le jeu du premier vertueuse alors
déclarer son patrimoine renonçait à sa
profession voilà des adresses qui pour
le moins que l'on puisse dire son passé
ou mal passée chez les élus d'ailleurs
même aller à l'assemblée nationale dans
les couloirs de l'assemblée nationale
jean baptiste daoulas a recueilli toutes
les impressions regarder rendre des
comptes wii est responsable oui se
mettre à poil nom hervé mariton ne
publiera pas son patrimoine
les députés sont divisées face à un
mouvement de transparence un peu trop
désorganisée d'autant qu'aucun
dispositif ne permet de contrôler leurs
déclarations promis que si jérôme
cahuzac par exemple d'autres publient
leur patrimoine
ils auraient indiqué qu'ils avaient des
comptes en suisse donc la seule manière
de savoir ça c'est donner des moyens
l'administration fiscale pour le
socialiste rené dosière la solution est
assez simple
spécialiste du train de vie des élus il
estime que l'état doit être en mesure de
répondre à une question très simple est
ce qu'un homme politique s'enrichit
durant sa carrière politique
mes deux seins un peu trop tendre avec
l'industrie pharmaceutique
avocat d'affaires qui mettrait son
carnet d'adressés de député à
disposition de ses clients les soupçons
de conflit d'intérêts sont nombreux
aujourd'hui le patron des députés ps
vont obliger les parlementaires à se
consacrer uniquement leur mandat je
crois que l'on doit savoir que quand on
est député
c'est pour un service exclusif de la
république une disposition jugée
démagogique par l'opposition à commencer
par bernard debré député et urologue
depuis hier je suis un parce que
j'ai un métier
je suis élu en 86 ça ne gênait personne
rien je opérait la moitié des
socialistes ça les a pas gênés ils ont
là la liste des professions incompatible
avec le mandat de parlementaire sera
défini dans le projet de loi alors
laurence rossignol
on voit que toute façon ce reportage
fait beaucoup commentée à droite à
gauche mais donc on va vous poser la
question quelles seraient les activités
incompatibles avec la loi molle a
compris peut-être médecins mais aussi
avocats
jusqu'où ça peut aller écouter toutes
les activités qui mettent en jeu des
intérêts particuliers qui peuvent entrer
en conflit avec l'intérêt général
un avocat d'affaires et c'est son boulot
défendent des intérêts particuliers
économique est souvent les intérêts
économiques en question s'affrontent
d'ailleurs avec les propositions de loi
les projets de loi et nous mêmes on est
soumis à beaucoup de pression
alors je vois pas comment on peut tout à
la fois conseiller un groupe industriel
et en même temps voter la loi l'intérêt
général et les intérêts particuliers
doivent être clairement séparés donc
avocat d'affaires c'est sûr c'est pas
possible les médecins également proche
de laboratoires pharmaceutiques
c'est non aussi c'était le cas de jérôme
cahuzac oui bien sûr les met tous les
gens qui sont liés avec des intérêts
économiques derrière sur les avocats
toujours étonné les avocats
parlementaires sont tous avocats
d'affaires j'en connais pas qui fait
dossier de divorce est quand même
bizarre 6e temps sont ici jean françois
copé pour ne pas citer de noms enfin un
médecin qui travaille dans un hôpital
des médecins je pense qu'avoir regarder
peut-être pour les gens qui font des
actes techniques chirurgiens
anesthésistes
moi j'ai une colline parlementaire qui
nous sont bernard debré on fait quoi on
lui retire son métier fait garder tout
ça il va falloir faire quoi du cas par
cas s'il est compliqué je vais vous dire
ce que je pense c'est qu'il faut
permettre à des gens qui ont un métier
avec une technique manuelle ce qu'est le
cas des chirurgiens de ne pas perdre
cette technique moi je connais une
parlementaire qui continue de faire une
garde par mois le samedi soir juste pour
payer le dit et dit c'est pour pas
oublié comment on fait j'ai besoin de
m'entraîner et le contact avec le
terrain voilà une garde cliquer cette
liste ans il va falloir aller dans le
cas de maria dans le médecin il ya ceux
qui peuvent ce qu'ils peuvent pas dans
les avocats ya ceux qui peuvent ce
qu'ils peuvent pas
les avocats n'ont qu'à ça va être aucun
voilà quand on est parlementaire on a
besoin de se consacrer à plein temps au
parlement ces parlementaires
demain matin ils sont plus éduqué ce que
vous faites vous même qu'est ce que vous
faites bien attention d'être élu dans
cherche du boulot il ya d'autres métiers
ou considérée comme une professionnelle
de la politique je considère que c'est
une activité à plein temps quand on la
pratique vous avez renoncé un autre
médecin j'ai renoncé j'ai renoncé tout
vous êtes déjà les gens nous disent on
trouve qu'on n'est pas suffisamment ou
devrait-on moment où ils nous regardent
alors on peut expliquer qu'on est en
commission peut expliquer qu'on est sur
le thème à messiaen plus on explique
qu'on est dans un bureau en train de
défendre les intérêts d'un groupe de
travail et de dire ça déconnecte du
terrain et de la réalité du monde du
travail est une hypocrisie formidable en
fait on prend ce qui est historique en
pour dire on est issu de cette tradition
de la république des avocats mais en
même temps on n'exerce plus la fonction
de parlementaire aujourd'hui comme sous
la troisième république
donc aujourd'hui c'est un job à plein
temps à plein temps et même double à 12
ans de la politique mais le temps on
l'est il faut qu'on soit exclusivement
concentrés sur cette activité là et puis
des avocats bas ils vont et quand ils
auront fini être parlementaire
je ne suis pas inquiète ils pourront se
réinscrire au barreau et pour retrouver
leur boulot d'avocat et et je pense que
pendant les périodes où ils ont été
parlementaires
ils auront un peu actualiser leurs
connaissances en droit
ils ont fait la loi donc on peut avoir à
être simplement parlementaire et ne pas
être déconnectés du terrain et du monde
de travail surtout pour être connecté au
terrain il faut voir les gens elle est
lui allé les voir comme des cils terrain
c'est d'avoir des liens avec des grands
groupes qui défend des intérêts
économiques c'est un terrain un peu un
peu hasardeuse alors de 800 à la sphère
cahuzac la pression ne s'est pas relâché
cette semaine sur pierre moscovici
ministre de l'économie le magazine
valeurs actuelles annonce avance qu'une
enquête parallèle aurait été secrètement
mené après les révélations mediapart
le même jour les présidents des
commissions des finances de l'assemblée
et du sénat sont allés à bercy pas
convaincu par l'existence d'une enquête
parallèle mais perplexe sur les réponses
de l'administration fiscale
rémy hartmann pierre moscovici savait-il
était-il au courant que jérôme cahuzac
avait eu un compte en suisse
le ministre de l'économie aurait-il
couvert son ministre du budget et
surtout l'administration fiscale at elle
mis tous les moyens pour obtenir la
vérité au sénat la droite a pilonné de
questions le patron de bercy qui a
répliqué en plaidant la bonne foi dans
cette affaire
l'administration fiscale a fait tout ce
qu'elle pouvait elle a fait tout ce
qu'elle devait dans le respect du droit
et prenons garde a ici le transformer la
faute d'un homme en attaque contre un
gouvernement coco ministres intègres
pierre moscovici ne répond plus
seulement aux attaques de l'opposition
mais à un article publié par le journal
valeurs actuelles
selon son auteur bercy aurait mené à la
fin de l'année dernière une enquête sur
les éventuels comptes en suisse de
jérôme cahuzac
mais une enquête a minima portant sur
une période où l'ex ministre avait déjà
fermé ses comptes helvétiques et
j'arrive à la conclusion eux qu'au mois
de décembre le ministre de l'économie et
des finances ne pouvait pas ignorer que
monsieur cahuzac avait un compte à l'ubs
et s alors 2002 que lorsqu'il dit gilles
ans due diligence une enquête à partir
du 23 janvier et qu'il l'a l'encadrent
de façon extrêmement stricte entre 2006
et 2012 2013
il avait la quasi-certitude qu'il ne
trouvait rien pour vérifier ces
informations
philippe marini et gilles carez se sont
rendus directement ministère de
l'économie
en tant que présidents des commissions
des finances du sénat et de l'assemblée
nationale
ils ont accès aux documents de
l'administration fiscale même ceux
couverts par le secret il est peu
plausible à mon avis qu'il y est eu une
mission diligentée en suisse ce ce genre
de choses je n'y crois pas sur le fond
des choses
nous restons je reste pour ma part tout
à fait sur ma faim pierre moscovici a
d'ores et déjà annoncé qu'il allait
porter plainte contre le journal valeurs
actuelles
les deux présidents de commission des
finances à bercy c'est vraiment un fait
exceptionnel
est ce que l'on se signale vous êtes
corps pour qu'il y ait une commission
d'enquêté parlementaire qui a été
demandé cette semaine à l'assemblée par
le groupe u10 je crois que le premier
ministre a répondu elle suit les vous
mais l'a dit oui bien sûr la différence
entre avant et maintenant c'est que
avant quand nous demandions des
commissions d enquête parlementaire nous
ne pouvions pas les obtenir
maintenant quand l'autre aux états unis
selon les sondages est réalisé par
exemple aujourd'hui quand l'opposition
demandent une commission de quelques
parlementaires nounou elle la voit là et
la transparence la même cave à lui pour
la presse dans le travail qu'elle a fait
sur la sphère cahuzac la justice qui a
pu travailler dans ton toute
indépendance
cette même indépendance du parlement est
respectée aujourd'hui c'est important
mais sur les deux présidents des
commissions des finances
ils font leur travail c'est leur pouvoir
d'investigation mais je trouve quand
même assez vicieux zaman anti raconte
les choses quand ils sortent ils sont
partis là bas ils sont partis à bercy
pour identifier et trouver des documents
prouvant qu'il y aurait eu une enquête
complémentaire fait en suisse il
ressortit disent bon alors on n'a pas
trouvé donc ce qu'on est venu chercher
on n'a pas trouvé
mais par ailleurs on n'est pas convaincu
ça veut dire quoi et je comprends pas
qu'ils ont encore un doute mais ils ont
un doute sur quoi ils sont venus
chercher quelques jolis moi j'ai un
doute sur autre chose
je comprends pas pourquoi c'est
maintenant qu'ils font ça parce que
depuis le mois de décembre ce pouvoir
d'investigation il l'avait déjà et j'ai
entendu saluer et loué les compétences
techniques du ministre du budget le
disque mais à la lecture du journal
valeurs actuelles qui aurait dû des
informations supplémentaires parce que
ils ont découvert les informations en
lisant valeurs actuelles
c'est vraiment été les derniers prévenus
de la république mais il aurait plu dès
le mois de décembre entend derrière des
les révélations de mediapart il aurait
pu aller investiguer à bercy mais
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas il servait
doute si ce que vous les doutes dont ils
n'avaient pas de doute apparemment ou
leurs doutes leurs sont venus à la
lecture de valeurs actuelles
je trouve qu'il ya une espèce de
manipulation l'utilisation politicienne
un peu de dernière minute
et puis une petite un petit temps de
retard dans leur pouvoir de contrôle
géré moscovici dans le viseur ce qu'il
peut encore tenir haut la vue sur les
images est extrêmement marqué m'a coûté
ya de quoi être marqué déjà une europe
et dans une tourmente budgétaire qui
fait qu' il est très présent
c'est une affaire dans son propre
ministère qui n'est pas unique et une
affaire douloureuse affectivement
personnellement et puis qu'est difficile
vainqueur difficile je comprends qu'il
soit marqué bon ceci dit de la a et
faire des commentaires politiques en
fonction des cernes sont les paroles des
points qu'on les ministres tout le monde
bosse en ce moment est lui aussi
beaucoup c'est sûr la presse les unes de
presse notamment cette semaine
ce qu'on va appeler le hall en belgique
où la une du point la une de l'express
notable aux caisses qui se profile
monsieur fait exprès mais j'ai pas
trouvé faible cette semaine mais il ya
toujours cette ambiguïté la presse et
amusantes tantôt elle en sens et tantôt
elle bâche bon hollande tantôt c'est le
faible
tantôt c'est celui qui impressionne
parce qu'il surprend parce qu'il n'est
pas faible
donc si on regarde depuis deux ans oui
on se fait dominer la une sur le fermé
toute façon dans un moment comme ça bien
entendu la presse dit ça ce serait le
contraire qui serait étonnant alors sur
votre parti le parti socialiste vous
avez vu peut-être il ya un sénateur qui
a la dent dure contre le parti
socialiste il s'agit de gaëtan gorce on
a pu lire son blog cette semaine un
message publié
eh bien il va pas de main morte lui
aussi il parle de clans à l'intérieur du
parti socialiste deux influences des
chefs de cynisme qui prennent la place
des convictions est ce qu'il ya une
dérive clanique au ps laurence rossignol
bouquet porte parle non je vois pas de
dérive clanique au ps
je trouve que d'abord harlem désir le
premier secrétaire avait pas un homme de
clan loin de là c'est un individu qui
est plutôt autonome il n'est rattachée à
aucun clan après il ya des choses qu il
ya des luttes d influence
oui mais pas tellement ce moment est le
parti socialiste est plutôt dans une
dans une démarche qu'une démarche à la
fois de soutien d'explication et de
propositions par rapport à l'appui du
gouvernement
je trouve pas que le blog de gaëtan
gorce soit bienvenus ni même que ceux
qui proposent soit utile les traits du
rhin c'est à dire de l'intérieur sont
peut-être les pierres pour une partie
des riffs clanique le ps confisqué par
une bourgeoisie d'appareils plus de plus
de conviction du cynisme froid jamais
malheureusement alors vous voyez
d'harlem désir elle a été traitée de
repris de justice cette semaine par
christian jacob
c'est très bas et elle l'ump cherche à
faire quelque chose dans lequel on veut
pas rentrer
c'est l'escaladé dans la violence
verbale
moi je n'ai pas du tout envie de sortir
les listes des mis en examen condamné de
l'ump mais on les a aussi si vraiment
ils le font les as moi ce que vous
qualifieriez aujourd'hui ce climat à
cette loi depuis quinze jours trois
semaines qu'on sent monter qu'il est
vraiment pas comme les autres des autres
partis dits extrêmes cible je crois que
ce n'est bon pour personne
l'ump me paraît bien pressé bien pressé
d'année
gouverner que le front national parce
que c'est quand même ce qu'il attendrait
assez rapidement fait monter les
enchères dans la vie dans l'agressivité
et essayer surtout de faire un vrai
contre-feu pour ne pas avoir à répondre
à une seule question à laquelle ils ont
toujours pas répondu
qu'est ce que vous allez faire sur les
lois que de moralisation que le
président de la république a présenté
cette semaine vous votez pour vous voté
contre
ils étaient opposés à la réforme du
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
pour donner encore plus indépendance à
la justice c'est pour ça qu'on avait
pris du retard
maintenant est-ce qu'ils sont toujours
opposés et valorisation vous les mettez
ça dans les prochaines heures et
prochains
mais c'est la vraie question qui va
intéresser les français allez on va
reprendre le fil de la semaine sur ce
qui intéresse peut-être le plus les
français les dossiers de fond et mardi
on parle emploi
le projet de loi sur la sécurisation de
l'emploi est votée ce mardi à
l'assemblée il reprend quasi fidèlement
l'accord signé entre le patronat et
trois syndicats représentatifs
les autres syndicats ce qui n'avait pas
signé avait appelé à une manifestation
vers l'assemblée nationale et lisa
bertolo me les débats ont duré une
semaine
un temps relativement long pour
finalement peu de modifications
conformément à l'accord signé par les
partenaires sociaux le projet de loi sur
la sécurisation de l'emploi accorde plus
de flexibilité aux entreprises tout en
garantissant davantage de sécurité aux
salariés une avancée souligné par le
ministre du travail
c'est ça l'objectif de cet accord de cet
accord et de cette loi sur la
sécurisation de l'emploi permettent aux
entreprises de s'adapter plus vite pour
permettre aux entreprises d'embaucher
plus vite et plus longtemps
c'est véritablement un texte de lutte
pour l'emploi et contre le chômage
les députés ont donc voté l'extension
d'une complémentaire santé à tous les
salariés
les accords de maintien dans l'emploi
l'encadrement des plans sociaux
la mobilité interne des salariés en cas
de difficultés dans l'entreprise
peu avant le vote la cgt fo la fsu et
solidaires les syndicats non signataires
de l'accord manifestaient soutenus par
les élus front de gauche
il espérait faire fléchir le
ernement ce n'est pas du tout un accord
donnant donnant comme le dit michel
sapin
mais c'est un accord donnant perdant on
voit bien l'intérêt qu'ont les
employeurs à avoir plus de flexibilité
plus de mobilité
une remise en cause du contrat de
travail aux bons souhaits des employeurs
par contre pour les salariés ont ils ont
bien du mal à nous démontrer qu
effectivement ça permettra de répondre à
l'objectif fixé qui était la création
d'emplois dans notre pays
les députés ont voté le texte vers 17
heures ce mardi mais avec une abstention
record de 278 voix parmi eux l'ump
les écologistes lui dei et 35 députés
socialistes alors laurence rossignol le
texte évidemment va passer chez vous au
sénat
on voit que les socialistes à
l'assemblée les députés ont plutôt joué
le jeu ils ont transposé quasiment
l'état l'accord est ce que ce sera la
même chose à l'assemblée pardonnez-moi
mais a eu des amis importants et le
rapporteur jean marc germain disait qu'à
son sens 90% des problèmes qui ont été
soulevés contre autres par un syndicat
qui n'avait pas signé le texte était
avait trouvé une traduction dans les
amendements de l'assemblée nationale on
va essayer de faire pareil au sénat et
s'est améliorée parce que c'est rôle du
parlement alors on assure ne voteraient
pas en l'état vous allez amender le
texte de manière générale quand on a un
texte même issu du dialogue social il
faut chercher à faire le meilleur
travail parlementaire dessus donc je
pense que le sénat va encore améliorer
le texte
ça aide le gouvernement et ça aide aussi
les partenaires sociaux ne mendie
s'assurer qu'il soit votée telle quelle
haussier oui mais le gouvernement peut
pas demander des choses comme ça au
parlement oui il aimerait mais en même
temps le ministre michel sapin et quand
même s'est montré ouvert à des
améliorations voilà il faut 7 discute
avec les syndicats a fait que depuis
compliqué mais c'est ce qu'on a commencé
à faire c'est ce qu'on fait là déjà avec
les auditions et puis on fera le bilan à
la fin d'examen au sénat
qu'est ce que les syndicats peuvent
identifier comme amélioration dans le
texte
alors si les communistes votre compte si
les verts votre compte si la droite
s'abstient ou votre compte
ce texte les grandes chances de ne pas
passer au sénat 1
pourquoi les verts voteraient contre ces
eaux contre au sénat se sont abstenus à
l'assemblée oui ou s'abstenir s'abstenir
je sais pas ce que feront les autres
contes parlementaire probablement
effectivement qu'on communiste votre
accord beaucoup plus compliqué de le
faire passer ce sera compliqué ce qui
exigera un travail d'amendements et une
dentelle parlementaire encore plus si
nos parlementaires
bonjour les fragilités des majorité au
sénat alors passer au mercredi les
ministres lance une charge contre
l'austérité
c'est un appel lancé par des ministres
et non des moines celui d'arnaud
montebourg de benoît hamon qui
s'attaquent implicitement dans la presse
à la politique menée par leur propre
gouvernement jean marc ayrault en caisse
et françois hollande lui veut maintenir
le cap
joachim robe comme souvent c'est arnaud
montebourg qui a tiré la première salve
dans un entretien au monde le ministre
du redressement productif critique la
politique d'austérité qui conduit à la
débâcle
le sérieux budgétaire s'il tue la
croissance n'est plus sérieux il est
absurde et dangereux autres remises en
question celle de cécile duflot le
désendettement de la france ne présente
pas une solution à la crise affirme la
ministre du logement ce mediapart
le risque c'est la spirale de la
récession une inquiétude partagée par
benoît hamon dont le parisien
la france a besoin de reprendre son
souffle et le ministre délégué à
l'économie sociale et solidaire
d'enfoncer le clou sur des fl oods fait
partie de ceux qui considèrent que cette
politique est politique voulue par la
droite allemande est en train de mener
d'abord le projet européen dans une
impasse
trois ministres qui remettent en cause
ses orientations en pleine tempête
cahuzac françois hollande se passerait
bien de ce tir groupé
il s'est donc empressé de recadrer ses
troupes ils disent qu'il y à de
l'austérité en europe dans certains pays
mais aucun ministre du gouvernement ne
peut remettre en cause la politique qui
est conduite qui n'est pas le stérilité
recadrage en règle d'une injonction à
cesser la fronde les ministres concernés
n'ont pas réagi et benoît hamon a annulé
sa venue au sénat où il devait parler
d'économie sociale et solidaire
mais la polémique n'est peut être pas
terminée l'ailé gauche du parti
socialiste compte aborder le sujet de
l'austérité
lors du conseil national ça
à paris laurent son signal on sent bien
qu au sein du gouvernement il ya deux
lignes les sociaux-démocrates et puis
les autres notamment celui la ligne tenu
par arnaud montebourg benoît hamon
cécile duflot et d'autres qui se dégage
là encore ça je pense paquet de ligne au
sein du gouvernement ce qui vient de se
passer c'est que des ministres ont dit
comme des socialistes mais comme le
président de la république lui-même
l'avait indiqué dans son intervention
télévisée que l'austérité n'est en aucun
cas une solution pour l'europe et que
c'est une solution qui est porteuse de
gros orages et d'un grand désarroi pour
les peuples la question elle n'est pas
française et les européennes aujourd'hui
c'est est ce que la france peut porter
en europe une alternative à la ligne de
l'austérité porté par madame merkel est
la droite allemande lignes politiques
implantées par la france que la force
doit porter donc forcément ça me
chagrine politique française elle a une
politique française la l'orientation du
gouvernement elle est dans un cadre quel
cadre européen pour desserrer l'étau en
france il faut desserrer l'étau en
europe et ça ne peut pas se faire sans
que la france soit 13 offensifs et c'est
ce qu'on dit c'est mini c'est ce que
disait socialiste est ce que disent de
nombreux économistes
aujourd'hui l'austérité n'est pas le bon
choix pour l'europe et ce qui est dit
c'est que françois hollande a la
capacité et la volonté doit montrer à
toute l'europe n'arrive guère à
s'imposer face à angela merkel sur ce
sujet là oui mais ça l'était rapport de
force culturelle qui se font si en
europe tant que l'austérité parra est la
seule ligne pour l'europe c'est
difficile de s'imposer
à partir du moment où on entend des voix
s'élever les conservateurs espagnols
disent aujourd'hui le gouvernement
espagnol greenland droite dit
aujourd'hui
stop on n'en peut plus d'austérité et
donc il faut créer en europe un rapport
de force peut être composer avec une
partie des conservateurs européens qui
sont en rapport de force qui arrive à
faire bouger la ligne européenne
si on fait pas sens on y arrivera
marrant fou à laurence rossignol que le
gouvernement et romaine une politique
d'austérité
non je dis qu'il mène une politique de
sérieux budgétaire et que cette
politique de 5 du budget terre elle est
très dure
voilà ce que je dis en effet
elle est très dure et c'est pour ça que
heureusement dans l'appel dans laquelle
on est con un gouvernement de gauche
pour le faire parce qu'on arrive à
protéger l'essentiel de ce qui est notre
socle républicain commun l'école la
sécurité la justice et en d'autres mains
la même période
en d'autres mains qu'entre les nôtres
sur une pâle infiniment plus
dévastatrices si on prend juste
peut-être un exemple des 3% de déficit
la lutte pour autocars a baissé à 3 pour
se re continue continue pas parce que
c'est ça la ligne politique
ces salles à ce qu'on appelle de sérieux
budgétaire il faut la question est
malheureusement pas poser à la france
tout seul on peut pas répondre seul à
cette question là si on peut prendre une
seconde
très rare il faut quand même se dire non
on abandonne l'idée des 3% alors
seulement si on dit qu'on a abandonné 3%
c'est pas pour monter au delà de quatre
peut-être voilà il ya un seul set ce que
disent des économistes c'est que si un
effet sur les taux d'intérêt d'un
abandon d'aline et 3%
on risque de ne pas gagner un centime
d'euro supplémentaire de marge de
manoeuvre dans ce qui compte ce qui
compte c'est pas que la france
abandonnait elle seule les 3%
c'est que l'europe rompant avec le dogme
de la priorité aux déficits
allez on va passer au jeudi avec le
mariage pour tous au sénat l'examen donc
cette semaine du texte sur le mariage
pour tous voté vendredi les débats en
général on était plus serein qu'à
l'assemblée ce qui n'a pas empêché
quelques moments de tension notamment en
ce jeudi marie brémaud la star dans
l'hémicycle aujourd'hui c'était ce livre
violet durable et invoqué brandit le
règlement du cinéma je brandis vos
règlement du sénat 29 abyss lesieu
retailleau je vous donne bien volontiers
la parole pour un rappel au règlement
pour un rappel au règlement monsieur le
président en place et une séance bien
ajustés dans ce marathon législatif
la fatigue commence à se faire sentir
mais l'opposition est bien décidé à
faire durer les choses on ne parle pas
d'obstruction mais nous sommes là nous
travaillons est ce que je souhaite c'est
que on évite les manoeuvres de
retardement
malgré les appels répétés au règlements
et les tentatives d'apaisement du
président de séance
je veille à la sérénité de l'assemblée
nous allons reprendre sereinement les
travaux les paroles du sénateur ump
bruno retailleau
il faut mettre le feu dans l'hémicycle a
su madame benbassa écoutez nous n'avons
pas la même couleur politique
d'autres couleurs non plus trieurs mais
au moins on peut s'écouter on peut
s'entendre au delà de ses couleurs
variées mois là il n'y a aucun problème
des boutons qui suscite la colère des
élus écolos de dire nous ne sommes pas
de la même couleur politique
et d'ailleurs nous ne sommes pas de la
même couleur c'est inné station vos
propos monsieur retailleau c'est
scandaleux de pouvoir tenir des propos
comme ceux-là je demande tout simplement
non pas vos explications n'ont pas votre
diatribe que vous venez d'être faire
pour vous justifier
je vous demande des excuses à sa
l'ascension et aux débats qui
s'éternisent les sénateurs socialistes
se réunissent à la mi journée
il décide de ne pas accélérer la
procédure et de prendre leur mal en
patience ça ça nous contraint à être là
mais après tout si on est parlementaire
c'est pour être parlement n'est ce pas
sans ça il faut faire autre chose de
leur côté des parlementaires ump eux
aussi se concertent pour choisir
l'attitude à adopter
les esprits s'échauffent ans il était
temps de trouver un compromis et le
texte at-on capter a voté vendredi en
fin de matinée
vous avez suivi évidemment tous et tous
ces débats je vous avais trouvé comment
la teneur la tenue des débats en général
d comme souvent quand c'est des
procédures d'obstruction en première
partie discussion générale intéressante
chacun expose ses positions elles sont
pas les mêmes et puis après on rentre
dans l'obstruction parlementaire les
amendements les interventions répétition
et qui est des gens qui disent ne dirais
pas les parlementaires de l'opposition
qui répètent et répète la même chose au
bout d'un moment ça n'apporte plus grand
chose donc il faut faire il joue la
montre il faut faire durer le temps il
faut être là à attendre que le temps
dure voilà et des incidents de séance et
a vu avec notamment bruno retailleau
avec jean vincent placé
vous avez trouvé comment ce climat au
sénat c'est toujours un problème avec
l'obstruction c'est qu'au bout d'un
moment à force de rester enfermé dans
mame bocar elle pendant 50 heures ce qui
nous arrivait cette semaine ça comme ça
ça crée un peu de une ambiance un peu
confiné un peu électriques donc j'ai vu
effectivement j'ai un incident entre
bruno retailleau et esther benbassa je
comprends que certaines gaza était
choqué et je préfère pour nous tous et
pour l'institution penser que monsieur
retailleau faisait bien allusion à la
couleur de la vaysse de madame benbassa
et pas autre chose dans notre intérêt
commun on va admettre que sont les
organes attendant une prochaine
manifestation qui est annoncé pour le 26
mai j'irai pas au 112 films à succès
paru vous êtes d'accord
oui parce que effectivement il ya à
partir d'un mouvement qui était un
mouvement de jean qui était sincèrement
perturbé par ce projet une exploitation
politique et une radicalisation qui est
fait et j'espère surtout que les
organisateurs auront la vigilance de ne
pas cesser comme la fois précédente
débordés par des groupes d'extrême
droite c'est de leur responsabilité de
commencer maintenant à mettre de l'ordre
dans ce qu'ils vont faire
donc dans la pour la deuxième lecture à
l'occasion de la seconde lecture à
l'assemblée puis au sénat
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
merci beaucoup d'avoir
alors